there's a paradox to being human we are
at every moment of every day living a
paradox we are at every moment of every
day inherently
we are individuals and we're members of
groups
and every day we're forced to make
decisions should i put myself first
ahead of the group or should i put the
group first ahead of myself
and people debate it no no no you have
to take care of the group because
they'll take care of you
no no no you have to take yourself
because if you're not healthy how can
you take care of your group
you're both right and you're both wrong
it's not one or it's a paradox
and we have to deal with those stresses
every day milgram i mean
maslov only considered us as individuals
so his pro his buddha's blind was
was food and and security food and uh
and shelter and the third line up was
social connection
i've never heard of anyone committing
suicide because they were hungry
people commit suicide because they're
lonely which means
social connection is probably more
important than food
to some degree again oh yeah yeah but
you have to be fed first
i guess i know it's a paradox i get it
so to answer the question it's
unbelievably difficult
and if you only put yourself first and
your team sees you always putting
yourself first
you will not command trust or loyalty in
fact what will happen is they will put
themselves first
and that's going to be your corporate
culture uh it is difficult
and sacrifices need to be made everybody
has the capacity to be a leader like
everybody has the capacity to be a
parent
doesn't mean everybody should be a
parent doesn't mean everybody wants to
be a parent
same with leadership not everybody wants
to be a leader not everybody should be a
leader because you're going to make
personal sacrifices
on both sides your family will be
sacrificed at times to do the right
thing
for your people and sometimes you're
gonna have to sacrifice your people to
do the right things for yourself
it's unbelievably difficult
but if your family feels that you have
their back
they'll be supportive when you make
those sacrifices and if your people feel
that you have their back genuinely then
they'll be supportive when you make
those sacrifices
you